this is a next story is one of those
stories about the headline versus the
reality what I mean by that is we often
will come to you with a story where I
will tell you here's the headline of how
it's being reported and then here's the
reality or here's the sort of more
important angle Donald Trump and AIDS
are reportedly according to some
headlines on tape laughing and joking
about that horrible terrorist ambush
that took place in Nazaire in 2007 that
left four American servicemembers dead
now you might remember our coverage of
that incident it happened in October of
2017 nearly a year ago US Special Forces
were attacked and four of them ended up
losing their lives there is a recording
that has been made by former White House
communications aide Omarosa Manigault
lines would lead you to believe that
Trump is straight-up
laughing and joking about the deaths of
those for US military service members
now I'm gonna play it for you and if
you're like me you will quickly realize
that the news here is not Trump laughing
about the deaths of servicemembers but
it's something else
so let's take a listen to this clip we
want you less water for this
we have a lot of things happening on the
economic front
I think yet the military
you know and now one nice year so what
happens is we have decimated everything
so rough business they're rough to want
to kill us we've let the military do
what they have to do and what do you
call those of engagement or any what you
want to say it what we let them do and
did the Middle East is where if you left
we really we've done our job we've done
more in seven months to do at seven
months understand we've done more than
seven months of it and eight years and
so were they could there but what
happens is now they flee and they flee
that Africa and they leaked in Nigeria
surround them and that's how these you
know people get attacked and they got
attacked by fifty real fighters but
these were people in many cases that
were in the Middle East then now go to
Africa to try and
cause problems there and ultimately they
want to come back here because this is
where they really want to be so it's a
rough business I would I don't think I'd
want to be but but that it's the you
know people don't say that the reason
they're there is because we forced of
that and it's just that it's not nearly
as many it's not nearly as intense but
it's pretty intense and you see that
happening so that's then I think
Hilary's gonna kill Russia so the real
news here is not about Trump joking
about dead service members people are in
the room er laughing Trump does appear
to like with most things not understand
sort of the seriousness of what's going
on but it's it's just not accurate to
say Trump was laughing about the deaths
or even laughing about the ambush he was
laughing about the idea that it's really
bad to be a terrorist now because he's
going after people so hard
the real revelations from this clip are
number one even in the middle of all
this stuff related to knee chair Trump
still can't say knee chair that that's
notable because at that point he must
have heard it
I don't know hundreds of times from
people that are around him number two
that he has no idea what he's talking
about I mean this is a word salad
reminiscent of Sarah Palin who would
experience these completely futile
attempts to use language to communicate
anything of meaning Trump seemingly
falling into sort of that's that same
thing and number three even in private
Donald Trump was still transitioning
from talking about this ambush in
Nazaire to talking about Hillary
colluding with Russia that's the news
here it's not clear that Trump has any
clue what the hell he's talking about
and as far as Trump telling jokes and
his sense of humor the guy has a real
you know what one of the indications
that someone who may have sort of some
serious either personality issues or
mental illness or emotional issues
is that their sense of humor seems very
off in different ways and this is not to
stigmatize any condition or to cast
aspersions it's just sometimes you
notice that somebody has something about
them that is not functioning completely
correctly based on their sense of humor
and what they seem to laugh at or not
laugh at Trump sense of humor has
something fundamentally wrong with it
you might remember he was roasted on
Comedy Central sometime ago and he
seemed completely unable to sort of get
what was going on and understand humor
you might remember years ago when
President Obama was still president that
Donald Trump was in the audience during
the White House Correspondents Dinner
and Obama told some quite frankly pretty
funny jokes about Donald Trump and Trump
simply did not laugh and it wasn't clear
that he wasn't laughing because he was
upset that he was that with the butt of
jokes it doesn't seem that he
understands satire or humor but for
whatever reason in this case even though
Trump's not laughing at dead soldiers he
found that the sort of circumstance
where he would joke in general and and
the the disgusting thing is really his
general handling of that ambush in
Nazaire we learned that while on the
phone with one of the wives widows of
one of the four deceased service members
Trump seemed to forget the name of the
service member in question and every
element of Trump's involvement with that
raid was despicable the raid itself its
planning the hugely questionable nature
of the raid to begin with Trump's
reactions to the death totally the
deaths plural totally deplorable but
this is not the the the the right
headline I believe and I think that
there is a lot of interesting stuff in
this recording from Omarosa by the way
what other recordings does she have
that's really a growing interesting
question but Trump is not laughing at
dead service members as was framed by
some but still a very interesting clip
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show if you aren't you were missing
behind the scenes pictures pictures from
what goes on in the studio from my
recent trip and also make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman quick break andrew sidle from the
Freedom From Religion Foundation joins
me next one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics the first 500 people
who click the link under this video will
get two entire months of totally free
access to every single class offered by
Skillshare you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between
I think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you I just
took a really fascinating class on
watercolour painting which I am not yet
at the level of trying to perfect but
more the level of trying to learn even
just a little bit about our show is
giving you two entire months of totally
free access to every course offered by
Skillshare risk free if you click the
link under this video you'll have two
whole months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share your passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up